i have no words but what did we just see
all right well today is national book
lovers day and rocky is exploring a
local spot where all the bookworms and
word nerds can celebrate
welcome to the writer's block a
brilliant play on words i might add drew
co-owner of this beautiful spot here in
downtown so let's cheers to national
book lovers day because what is a book
shop without coffee you got to have the
right vibe you got to set the vibe okay
and i imagine that this cage here in
your shop is a nod to i know why the
caged bird sings or it's like it's kind
of an all-purpose nod we are an
artificial bird sanctuary so that's part
of it and it's also a bit of a throwback
to old casino cages i love that we love
a vegas not okay so let's walk through
this beautiful shop tell us about the
lit scene here in vegas yeah so that
that the literary scene here has
expanded exponentially since we opened
seven years ago we have our independent
bookstore and coffee shop here
our building is also home to a variety
of writers and residents
that's cool and that makes sense to me
because this place feels like home thank
you it's so comforting yeah it's it's
really cool that that that we've got
that atmosphere with real writing going
on and we also um we also offer creative
writing workshops oh that's amazing and
those are starting again this saturday
okay and is this is this for adults and
children how does that work good
question these are just for children um
they're ages 5 through 18 at the
workshops um they are entirely free
and after a long hiatus we are bringing
them back on saturday oh congratulations
and i know because that is your pride
and joy here what do the kids actually
learn they actually they will write
creative stories usually fiction and
then they leave with a book at the end
of the workshop you're the children that
come take your writing courses
write an actual book they do you get
them printed exactly so we it is all
project based and results in a real book
a kid wrote this that is amazing that's
so cool okay so for kids at home or
parents at home watching and they want
to get their creative juices flowing
what's an exercise they can do at home
so they could try a game of like
exquisite corpse where each person uh
gives a line of the story and then the
next tries to complete it oh that's fun
okay give me a line give me a like okay
it was dark and stormy
and
i had to report outside
the sky very it was daunting that's good
do we do good okay you guys finished the
story at home i'll send it back to you
happy national book lovers day sure